Speaker 1: All right. Many of you have asked
me, David, do you think Marjorie Taylor GREENE,
the radical Trumpist Republican congresswoman, is
she really this dumb and ignorant when she says
things like her rights were frequently violated
or that there was a peach tree dish, or that
Nancy Pelosi's gazpacho, police did something.
Is she really this dumb or are these incredibly,
brilliantly orchestrated viral moments that
are contrived and planned to get her attention?
Or are they sort of like verbal glitches in the
style of Trump? So let's see if we can
figure it out one by one. First of all,
there's a new one of these. Marjorie Taylor
GREENE recently said that people were stroking
fear. Of course, the term is stoking fear.
Speaker 3: Stroking fear and paranoia and
everyone saying terrible messages ahead of time.
Speaker 1: Right. They were stroking fear. So
first and foremost, these are not the types of
glitches that Trump has when Trump has these
glitches. He either is having a problem
reading or he's having the brain glitch.
Speaker 2: No more. Drop the drop boxes.
Speaker 1: Exactly.
Speaker 2: I'm actually going. Sure. A rhino
named Mitt Romney or truth central. Anyway,
Donald Trump. Yeah, Donald Trump.
Speaker 1: Like Trump knows his own
name. That's just a verbal glitch.
Speaker 2: Oh, bummer.
Speaker 1: Yeah, he knows it. He knows it's Barack
Obama. So I would put the Marjorie Taylor GREENE
gaffes squarely outside of the kind of like brain
glitch Trump thing. So then the question becomes,
are these calculated or are these
just natural utterances? So again,
here's the latest one from yesterday stroking.
Speaker 3: Fear, stroking fear and paranoia and
everyone saying terrible messages ahead of time.
Speaker 1: Now, that one could be that she
misread it. I think maybe she doesn't know
the word stoking. She seems to be reading
on this one. We've then got one her writes were
frequently violated. If you have never smelled
Marjorie Taylor GREENE, be fragrant. Lee
violated. Then you don't know what's going on out.
Speaker 3: There and why their
due process rights are being so
fragrant. Lee And horrifically violated.
Speaker 1: So that one's not reading.
She's not reading that. Is that deliberate?
Is it some kind of brilliant joke which gets 5
million views and more? It doesn't feel like it.
It doesn't feel like it. Here's another example.
This is her infamous guest spot show. Police,
of course, hoping to refer to the Gestapo.
Speaker 3: Not only do we have the
D.C. jail, which is the D.C. gulag,
but now we have Nancy Pelosi's gazpacho,
police spying on members of Congress,
spying on the legislative work that we do.
Speaker 1: It doesn't seem contrived. It
seems like she really has no idea what
she's talking about. Here's the last
one where she referred to a petri dish as a
peach tree dish. Like, what could that even
mean? What does she think a peach tree dish is?
Speaker 3: You have to accept the fact that the
government totally wants to provide surveillance
on every part of your life. They want to know when
you're eating. They want to know if you're eating
a cheeseburger, which is very bad because Bill
Gates wants you to eat his fake meat that grows
in a peach tree dish, a pizza you probably get.
Speaker 1: I don't think that that's fake. I just
I just don't think that that's fake. I think she's
really that dumb. And it's nothing to make fun of.
I mean, education is her, so her being dumb is a
tragedy. Her being ignorant is a tragedy of the
American education system. People voting for her
anyway despite being so clueless. Is that also
because of the same education system or should
we be saying the real the real crazies? Are the
people voting for her? Like in most countries, if
someone like Marjorie Taylor GREENE ran for office
or something, she would just be laughed off of the
ballot. So maybe really the concern, as we've been
saying with Trump, is the people willing to vote
for her. Let me know what you think. I mean, as
I've said before, it's not particularly unusual
that people like Donald Trump exist or that
they might be narcissists and might want power
that exists everywhere. The difference is the
United States had 60 something million people.
I don't remember the numbers who in 2016 were
willing to vote for him to put him in power. That
seems to be the unique part of the United States
because, you know, Trump could just be some CEO
in a German boardroom or something like that. I'm
like, okay, there, these people exist everywhere,
but they wouldn't make them. The Prime Minister,
the the chancellor of Germany, I don't know. So
to me, it seems that this is this is really more
a reflection of the voters. Dumb people exist,
ignorant people exist. Marjorie Taylor GREENE
is one of them. It's in part a result of the
failing education system of the United States. But
I don't think these are contrived gaffes. I don't
think these are calculated viral moments. I think
she's just this dumb. Let me know if you disagree.